we the managers are not here
representing ourselves alone or even
just the house just as you are not here
making determination as the president's
guilt or innocence for yourselves alone
now you and we represent the American
people the ones at home and at work who
are hoping that their country will
remain what it has always believed it to
be a beacon of hope of democracy and of
inspiration to those striving around the
world to create their own more perfect
unions for those who are standing up to
lawlessness and to tyranny Donald Trump
has betrayed his o to protect and defend
the Constitution but is not too late for
us to honor ours to wield our power to
defend our democracy as President
Abraham Lincoln said at the close of his
Cooper Union address on February 7 1860
neither let us be slandered by from our
duty by false accusations against us nor
frightened but from it by menaces of
destruction to the government nor of
dungeons to ourselves let us have faith
that right makes might and in that faith
led us to the end dared to do our duty
as we understand it today we urge you in
the face of overwhelming evidence of the
president's guilt and knowing that if
left in office he will continue to seek
foreign interference in the next
election to vote to convict on both
articles of impeachment and to remove
from office Donald J Trump the 45th
president of the United States
you